marketing is all around us and it's
constantly evolving the world has gone
digital and so has marketing over 64
percent of adults who use the internet
based their purchasing decision on what
they read online and that can range from
social media and emails to a news
article it is important now more than
ever to learn and understand the power
of digital marketing to keep your client
or customer engaged with your product or
service
analytics and metrics tools are rapidly
changing to meet the demands of today in
this nanodegree program you will have an
opportunity to build more data-driven
marketing insights about your customers
and digital presence using google
analytics and reimagine the future of
your marketing capabilities by exploring
newly emerging marketing technologies
you'll develop the skills needed to
define your business value proposition
marketing objectives and kpis target
personas and customer journey marketing
channels and content strategy
what makes this program special are all
the real world projects that we have in
it so you get to create and evaluate
advertising campaigns and then get
expert feedback to improve their results
now is the time to advance your career
in digital marketing enroll today in the
digital marketing nanodegree program